eu sou apaixonado por ciência
tenho 20 anos sou estudante de
engenharia química
sou do rio grande do sul e é a minha
segunda viagem que eu fiz de avião
a primeira foi em fevereiro e agora a
segunda na tão grandiosa sala são paulo
eu acho que se eu continuar nesse ritmo
talvez eu vá direto para a lua ou para
marte
eu trabalho em prol da divulgação
científica na área da astronomia que
visa divulgar e estudar os mecanismos do
nosso universo desde a sua criação
desenvolvimento ou até possível final
que possa acontecer daqui a milhões de
anos mas quando eu falo em ciência que
vem na mente de vocês como uma área que
é muito abrangente e nós temos várias
áreas do conhecimento
nós por nós podemos pensar em várias
coisas desde um cientista fazendo
experimentos no seu laboratório um
astrônomo olhando os céus à noite ou
coisas muito simples que nós fazemos no
cotidiano como por exemplo a preparação
de um bolo
a minha paixão por gastronomia pela
ciência ela começou quando eu tinha 13
anos
esse gordinho é isso eu estava no ensino
fundamental e eu era daquelas pessoas
que não gostavam de fazer educação
física então ia à biblioteca e procurava
por livros revistas etc e uma dessas
indas e vindas
eu encontrei no armário empoeirado um
box de um dvd chamado cosmos que foi
feito nos anos 80 por um dos maiores
divulgadores da ciência chamado carl
sagan inclusive em 2013 nós tivemos um
remake feito pelo negros tyson e ele que
foi o responsável por plutão não ser
mais um planeta lá em 2006 eles
classificaram o botão de um planeta pra
planeta não então para quem gostava de
plutão a culpa do lei do estágio
pois bem eu era uma criança muito
curiosa e ainda sou uma criança muito
curiosa então eu tentava procurar as
respostas
tudo o que acontecia ao meu redor eu era
tão curioso que eu acho que até às vezes
era muito chato e tudo que eu queria era
não tem aquele clichê duhá porque nós
temos a lua gira em torno da terra
porque sim porque o céu é azul porque
sim eu queria sair desse clichê que iria
achar as respostas para essas perguntas
como por exemplo eu acho que todo mundo
aqui já teve a oportunidade de
presenciar um pôr-do-sol correto
se eu falar para vocês que quando o sol
ele desce no nosso horizonte
ele não está mais lá vocês vão me achar
que eu sou maluco mas eu posso explicar
isso melhor
a distância entre a terra eo sol é de
aproximadamente 150 milhões de
quilômetros
a velocidade da luz é de 300 mil
quilômetros por segundo
então o tempo que a luz do sol chega até
os nossos olhos é de aproximadamente
oito minutos logo se hipoteticamente o
sol apagasse nesse momento nós só
conseguimos observar oito minutos depois
de uma noite de céu limpo sem nuvens
a poluição luminosa nós conseguimos
saber observar a aproximadamente de 3 a
5 mil estrelas
só que eu perguntei a nossa galáxia tem
aproximadamente 300 milhões de estrelas
como é que a gente consegue viver só de
3 a 5 mil estrelas no céu porque assim
não existe uma resposta na astronomia
existe uma escala que nós chamamos de
magnitude
a magnitude é dada pela classificação de
brilho de corpos celestes para ser uma
forma didática a lua que é o corpo
celeste mais brilhante da noite em uma
magnitude de menos 11 ou seja quanto
mais negativo foi nessa escala mais
brilhantes será esse corpo celeste só
que não para por aí
nós não temos só uma galáxia nossa via
láctea
em 2010 o telescópio espacial hubble ele
fotografou um pequeno frame do nosso
universo uma pequena fotografia e nessa
imagem ele conseguiu fotografar mais de
mil galáxias é muita coisa então a
astronomia ela nos leva também a fazer
uma reflexão de que nós não somos o
centro do universo existem coisas ao
nosso redor e que nós deveríamos olhar
de uma maneira mais pertinente mais
aprofundada
porém seja por nossas rotinas do dia a
dia a correria do trabalho a gente não
consiga fazer isso
todas essas questões me fizeram remeter
a uma só pergunta
e pra quem tinha muitas perguntas foi
até um alívio porque nós não
conseguiremos de divulgar esses assuntos
para mais pessoas e se mais pessoas
tivessem acesso a esse conhecimento será
que eles seriam eu sei que elas estariam
tão fascinadas quanto eu quando eu sou
por isso eu criei a sete anos atrás o
projeto ciência astronomia que tem
justamente esse objetivo de divulgar de
forma acessível a crianças adolescentes
jovens adultos idosos formas de que a
ciência esteja mais presente no nosso
dia a dia e de forma acessível então são
feitas palestras em escolas são feitas
oficinas para crianças são feitas
oficinas de construção de telescópios
com baixo custo
lançamento de foguetes usando o próprio
lente vinagre e também bicarbonato que
aquilo que a gente usava no ensino
fundamental para fazer os vulcões de
lavar etc era então as crianças elas não
têm só aquela questão de falar de
aprender elas têm aquele sentido
palpável da ciência
uma das coisas que eu mais gosto de
fazer é colocar ao telescópio em praças
públicas
eu peço autorização pra prefeitura etc
coloco o telescópio à disposição e quem
estiver lá pode olhar pode fazer
perguntas
porém eu fazer isso até janeiro e leva a
filosofia de que o conhecimento é a
única coisa que a gente não perde nessa
vida ea minha paixão é poder divulgar a
ciência
eu tive que vender esse telescópio para
ele aquela palestra que eu falei no
início do ataque na campus party
porém às vezes o universo conspira ao
nosso favor
uma pessoa que eu nunca vi na vida
ficou sabendo do projeto entrou em
contato comigo e gostou da iniciativa e
do um telescópio muito maior melhor e eu
tenho muito que agradecer essa pessoa
inclusive hoje de maneira especial
porque ela está aqui nesse exato momento
na platéia então aonde quer que você
esteja o meu muito obrigado então a
astronomia ela leva não só essa questão
de observar mas também sentir a gente
tem uma sensação e ao longo desses sete
anos eu já tive vários depoimentos e
dentre eles eu tenho um que eu queria
muito compartilhar com vocês porque é o
que eu mais meu eu mais me emociono que
foi há três anos atrás eu coloquei os
telescópios numa cidade chamada
cachoeirinha e uma senhora de 83 anos
ela observou olhou por dois minutos pelo
colar que é por onde a gente olha o
telescópio pediu para olhar mais um
pouquinho
ela está observando saturno e depois
disso ela com os olhos cheios de
lágrimas me abraçou e falou meu filho
ao longo dos meus 83 anos
essa foi a coisa mais fascinante que eu
vi na minha vida então isso mexe com a
gente porque
chegar é uma relação entre a ciência a
pessoa e quem divulga então tem essa
conexão intensa docente o que a pessoa
está sentindo naquele momento porém eu
queria ir mais longe
eu não posso só atingiu o público da
minha cidade e ao redor
vamos pra internet essa teia que liga o
mundo então vamos conseguir mais pessoas
e com isso nós criamos o projeto no
youtube
eu e mais alguns colegas nós fazemos
transmissões ao vivo todos os sábados
envolvendo temas relacionados à ciência
e que temos sempre convidados que
trabalham já dentro para tirar dúvidas
de pessoas e também fazemos transmissões
de eventos astronômicos ou seja eclipses
tipos de meteoros ocultações de planetas
e etc
e há dois meses atrás me aconteceu uma
coisa que eu nunca acreditei na minha
vida que acontecerá dia 27 de setembro
nós tivemos um eclipse lunar
não sei se todos acompanharam e várias
cidades do brasil estava um com céu
nublado e nós transmitimos eu e mais
alguns colegas que fazemos divulgação
científica
a nasa agência espacial americana
conseguiu um extreme um pico de pessoas
de 63 mil pessoas
nós do projeto ciência astronomia
conseguimos um pico de 83 mil pessoas
chupa naça
eu acho que depois de se desculpar nas
minhas probabilidades de visitar ou
estudar lá ou acabar mas enfim
então existe essa potência de que as
pessoas querem procurar querem que a
busca do saber que querem conhecer
coisas novas querem explorar o universo
e eu quero que o projeto ajude aos
adolescentes jovens em prol da ciência
que eles sejam os cientistas que sejam
tocados e fascinados para que nós
tenhamos maiores cientistas no brasil
que nos ajudem na tecnologia ciência que
eu quero também é que as pessoas saiam
daquele porque sim porque sim
não existe porque assim vamos buscar as
respostas para as coisas que acontece ao
nosso redor
existem tantas coisas que são que
acontecem no nosso dia a dia e se nós
olharmos com um olhar mais aprofundado
se tornam tão fascinantes porque o mundo
precisa de pessoas mais curiosas
obrigado